adrian hauser hauser looking to get back
into the win column for the first time
in a while right yeah he's lost three
straight decisions he's got to turn that
around
really castrating 325 in his 40th match
steps to the plate with a chance to
deliver a big early hit first pitch
swinging in a little soft tapper down
the first base line
hugs the line is it going to stay fair
it stays on the line
and it stays fair incredible
that ball goes foul 98 of the time and
it just stayed on the first base line
maybe 15 feet from home narvaez could
only
watch and it's stuck it's another
infield dribbler for a single
raya scores one-nothing tigers trying to
limit the damage to one run
as bonifacio comes to the plate ahead of
bonifacio righty on righty battle the
one-two pitch swinging a fly ball
left center field this one's deep this
one's way back in this ball is one hop
over the wall in left center field
bonifacio with a ground rule two run
double and the tigers take a three
nothing lead here in the first
well what a good buggy bug who up double
bogey with that time to drive in two
runs that ball looked to me like was off
the plate away
he read the breaking ball it was up a
little bit but that's that leverage
swing that we love to talk about spencer
turnbull seventh start averaging about
five a start
now the two-two swung on and missed
down goes yellow john strikes he wants
to bounce back
after well not very good at bat his
first time up with the bases loaded
here comes the one two he goes the other
way that's gonna drop in front of yelich
candelario trots home tigers lead at
four
nothing here in milwaukee good piece of
hitting from kristen stewart
really was slaughtered
[Music]
i mean it was a hittable pitch but uh
the two seamer runs a good amount
the brewers trying to put something
together against turnbull
in the third had a threat in the second
came away with a zero
eight homers driven in 18. there's a
swing and a drive
center field it's a one-run game
how about that he was talking about that
two-seamer after he rounded out on the
slider he said the two seamers to pitch
he got one hit it out i think maybe
testing should lift every day
how about that is that ball just jump
off his back
here comes the three two to castro on
the ground and by a diving justin smoke
into right field
that'll drive in cabrera tigers lead is
now
two willie castro with a three for three
night
get it in it was out over the plate
willie castro gets the bat on the ball
infield in
in for an rbi single plenty of game left
but a golden opportunity for narvaez who
struck out twice
good speed at third not so much at
second
[Applause]
busted bat flare shadow right out is the
second baseman it's down a hit
yelich is in smoke is in the third
garcia
tie game five five brewers good base
running on the bases right there
recognize right away that ball wasn't
going to be caught
looked like scope that came too far away
from it
not able to get there and two runs in
tie game
crew is finally able to cash in with the
bases loaded
obviously milwaukee doesn't have nearly
the amount of hits
the tigers had last night but they've
had some quality at-bats here's another
3-2
this one on a line scopes got it and
they double up
that's a huge way to end the inning and
the brewers will have them loaded with
one out
and so a big opportunity here for the
crew in a five five ball game
with eric sogart coming to the plate oh
to pitch so guard
lines this into deep center field this
is going to be deep enough to score a
run reyes over there to catch it
and tagging and scoring from third is
smoke
got him another great change up
he has struck out at least one batter in
every appearance
this season averaging over two
strikeouts per inning
not too shabby look at it here it is
kind of the old
pedro martinez change-up
0-2 pitch god stewart he strikes out two
in a perfect
eighth inning and jace peterson will
indeed hit
for garcia high drive
deep right center peterson with the
insurance shot of the night
a two-run blast to give the brewers a
three-run advantage
[Applause]
well that was a no doubter to write wow
boy did he get extension on that pitch
farmer left that one right down the
middle of the plate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now the pitch swaying and a miss struck
him out and this one is over
for brewers who were down four nothing
in the third
come back and beat the tigers 8-5